con solo un traje de baño un gorro
lentes y protección para los oídos
Bárbara Hernández hizo historia al
convertirse en la primera persona en
nadar dos kilómetros y medio en aguas
del Océano Antártico y el corazón Los
anteojos no se sentía que de rato pasaba
como algo helado que no es la piel es
como adentro
y es que a cada brazada quedaba
Hernández estaba un poco más cerca de
sufrir una hipotermia que puede provocar
una parada cardíaca y finalmente la
muerte pero ella no se detuvo hasta
alcanzar la boya que marcaba que había
logrado su meta en ese mar gélido apenas
dos grados Celsius
[Música]
fue un out súper difícil duro porque
es un lado muy largo entonces antes de
completar la primera milla como que
sentía que no llevábamos nunca a la boya
y voy muy concentrada como en la técnica
en el pateo obvio que siento los brazos
cada vez más pesados porque la sangre se
empieza a golpear o sea lo que hace el
cuerpo es deja de la sangre deja de
circular a manos y pies cuando la podada
sirena del hielo salió del agua le
tuvieron que sacar toda la ropa para
abrigarla y llegó a la enfermería con
una temperatura corporal de 27 grados
algo que muchas personas no habrían
podido soportar y que le ha abierto la
puerta el reconocimiento de la
asociación de natación internacional de
invierno y también al récord guinness
que se espera que le concedan por esta
marca ahora su próximo destino es Nueva
Zelanda para asistir a la competición
Seven Ocean